in this video we'll talk about the c
reactive protein test or crp test this
is kind of a blood test
but
what is it used for
the crp may be used for to monitor the
inflammatory status inside your body but
why the inflammation is caused in the
body
it might be due to a bacterial infection
might be due to a fungal infection or
might be due to a autoimmune disorder
such as lupus or rheumatoid arthritis
so let's look at the c reactive protein
in bit more details it's a ring-shaped
pentametric protein found in blood
plasma and its circulating concentration
rises with inflammation generally liver
secretes this particular protein
but how does liver know when to secrete
this protein or how does liver know
there is an inflammation in the body
and this signal is provided by
adipocytes or macrophages which is one
type of immune cell so these cell types
actually secrete chemical molecules
which tell the
liver about the status of inflammation
and as a response liver secretes c
reactive protein
so let's look at the biological function
of c reactive protein now this c
reactive protein can actually bind to
lysophosphatidyl choline which is
otherwise found in dead and decaying
cells
and after binding to this particular
protein it can activate complement
system which is one kind of inner immune
response
so the c reactive protein can bind to
this specific lysophosphatidyl choline
and ultimately it can recruit or
interact with a protein called c1q which
is a complement protein ultimately it
leads to the activation of complement
cascade
from an inflammation point of view or
infection point of view this is really
important for example there is a
bacteria so obviously this c reactive
protein can lead to complement fixation
of the bacteria and thereby lysis or
destruction of this bacteria it's kind
of like a protective mechanism
so
other than that there are several cell
types such as neutrophil macrophages
nk cells and dendritic cell all of them
has
anti-complement receptors so obviously
whenever there is a complement quotation
on the bacteria these cells would engage
with the bacteria and engulf them and
thereby neutralizing the threat and
reducing the
infection
now let's talk about what really happens
during a crp test it's just a blood test
so
a medical operative would take blood
from your veins and this is very simple
you need to know that whether you need
to do or you need to prepare somehow
before this test and the answer is no
you don't really need any other special
preparation before this test there is no
risk associated with this test so what
do you
i mean how do you interpret the test
results so there is a range which is
provided for crp the normal biological
range a range higher than that would
mean there is some kind of inflammation
in your body here we need to understand
that a crp test does not explain the
cause or the location of inflammation
it's just a screening test just going to
tell us whether there is inflammation or
not further test along with crp test is
required to
decide something conclusive like a
complete blood count like esr test all
of these tests would give us a holistic
picture and crp is just a screening
method quick screening method
now let us look at some patient data
quickly to understand what does those
data mean here are data from three
patient look at the patient one it has
the crp level 0.96 mg per liter that
means its crp level is fairly low in
this patient's body there is no
inflammation look at patient 3
the crp level is 44.89
mg per liter which is huge
that means high level of inflammation is
going on in the patient tree's body
now that kind of mean many things first
of all there is a inflammatory response
in the patient tree's body also there
could be increased chances of
cardiac diseases in patient 3 which one
is true that's why for the test is
required so for example in this patient
three
if doctor perform a blood test they
found this observation
look the neutrophil level has gone up
and neutrophil level increase is a
characteristic signature of a bacterial
infection that means while the blood
test was performed performed this
patient 3 was actually
suffering from some kind of bacterial
infection which has caused huge
inflammation in his body and that's the
interpretation from this particular
result there could be alternative
interpretation as well the patient
three could also suffer from cardiac
disease but further tests are required
to understand
or confirm that
idea or interpret something like that
anyway
when you have a crp level which is
beyond the range you should always
consult a doctor and take the advice of
a doctor anti-inflammatory medications
might help to reduce the inflammation in
the body for temporary sources but the
for permanent solution you should always
take doctor's advice and follow that
by the way notes and flash cards
associated with many videos are shown in
the facebook page the facebook page link
is provided in the description do check
it out as usual don't forget to like
share and subscribe
support my channel on patreon and
if you are a indian viewer you can take
my courses in an academy which is
india's biggest online learning platform
you can use my code ap10 to get a 10
discount and if you wish to connect with
me all the social media links are
provided in the description see you in
the next video